hey guys it's justine and today we are
doing something really fun not only are
we gonna have an unboxing of the simple
human clean station which can clean your
phone in 30 seconds and get rid of about
99.9 percent of germs
but we're also doing a 30 second
challenge of some suggestions of things
you'd like to see me complete
while my phone is being cleaned in 30
seconds a huge thank you to simplehuman
for sponsoring this video
this is gonna be incredible because i'm
so obsessive about germs and cleaning
so the fact that this is something that
i can basically just put my phone into
it will automatically raise and lower
your phone so it's kind of a touch free
experience
which is really cool because inside of
it it has 30 uvc
leds to kill 99.9 of germs across the
entire phone
let's unbox it and get cleaning it kind
of looks like a little
toaster for your phone i love this
[Music]
i'm a huge fan of simple human you guys
may have seen trash cans that i have
around the house
i even have one that's voice activated
that i say open can and you know what it
does
it opens the can
oh it actually looks like a mini version
of the trashcan
this is so cute wow
it really looks like a little toaster
it's super cute
all right here we go
the suspense
it's killing me
this is the coolest thing ever yeah you
put it in there
so tyler has an iphone 12.
[Music]
like i this is so it's like i know you
guys love space traveling
and you know things like that but this
this
is the future oh you want to live on
mars ah i'll be here cleaning my phone
in 30 seconds to get rid of 99.9 of the
[Music]
germs
i'll clean my friend's phone thank you
you're welcome so you guys challenged me
on some things that you'd like to see me
try to complete in 30 seconds while my
phone is cleaning
so let's take a look at what some of
those are and hope that i'll be able to
complete them
the first one is from mark and he wants
me to neatly fold
a fitted sheet that might be like
my biggest nightmare i like that he said
neatly
[Music]
out
oh i honestly think that
my talent is unmatched this one says
chainsaw i don't know what that means we
all know i love
my chainsaw i'll chainsaw something for
30 seconds
[Music]
am i done yet
i think this whole tree is dead to be
honest with you
are you okay
[Music]
rubik's cube oh i can only solve in
under three minutes so i don't know
about 30 seconds
oh yeah i got this
[Music]
30 seconds whoa sign me up for whatever
rubik's cube tournaments coming up next
oh a fitness challenge
do as many barbell squats or bw
pull-up i don't know what bw means and i
can't do pull-ups because i don't have a
pull-up bar
so i'll just do some squats do not let
me go
a second over 30 seconds
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
i would have seen why are there no
weights on your barbell don't judge me
[Music]
i wasn't counting makeup a 30 second
makeup challenge
accepted set a timer for 30 seconds
30 seconds
[Music]
such beauty as this
no come on i didn't even get my lipstick
on
[Music]
find an air tag within 30 seconds huh
okay all right tyler 30 seconds ready
let's roll
[Music]
how did you get in here
we'll put my keys in the tomatoes who
change an apple watch band
[Music]
[Applause]
did i make it put together your perfect
cheeseburger and artfully photograph it
get out of here
[Music]
artfully photograph
flip water bottle challenge
i don't know how to do that
oh that's hard why would someone suggest
this
close it's close
i hate this oh my god
i'm so talented
it was under 30 seconds it was i win
we're done
that was our last suggestion so guess
what
i win everything what do i win i win a
clean phone
well guys thank you so much for watching
this video this is such a cool new
product
i'm very very excited about this i just
love how sleek
and small it is and the fact that it's
automatic i can just drop my phone in
and then take it out when it's done i'll
put a link in the description if you
guys want to get more information or to
purchase one of these
and again a huge thank you to simple
humans for sponsoring this video i'm
such a huge fan of all of their products
so the fact that they are here
supporting my channel with this
incredible new product i am
so excited about so i will see you guys
in the next video bye
at this point i've cleaned it so many
times it's gonna be extra clean
[Music]
you